في هذه الأثناء، ترتفع معدلات تشخيص السرطان
بين الشباب الأميركيين،
وذلك وفقًا
لدراسة جديدة تمولها الحكومة نُشرت للتو،
ووجدت أن النساء في الثلاثينيات من العمر
قادن هذه الزيادة بأغلبية كبيرة،
كبير المراسلين الطبيين لدينا، الدكتور
سانجاي جوبتا، ينظر إلى كل هذا.
مندهش جدًا من أن النساء
صغيرات جدًا في الصباح،
نعم هذا نوع من
التحذير، وأعتقد أنه يتعين علينا أن ننظر إلى هذه
البيانات ونقرأها ونفهم
ما يحدث هنا إذا تم
تشخيص شخص ما تحت سن الخمسين، فهذا
يعتبر تشخيص مبكر للسرطان بداية مبكرة،
ما كانوا يحاولون
اكتشافه هو مدى تغير هذا
على مدى السنوات العشر الماضية أو نحو ذلك، ما الذي
نراه هل نرى المزيد من هذه الحالات
يتم تشخيصها لدى الشباب
والإجابة كما قلت تمامًا  نعم، إن
الأشخاص في الثلاثينيات من العمر هم الذين
يقودون هذه الزيادة في المقام الأول والنساء في المقام الأول
دعوني أريكم فقط لكل 100000
في عام 2010، حيث تم تشخيص حوالي مائة حالة
في تلك الفئة العمرية
تقدم سريعًا لمدة 10 سنوات تقريبًا وهي أقرب
إلى 103. لذا  إنها زيادة بنسبة ثلاثة بالمائة تقريبًا
خلال تلك السنوات العشر، وهذا لا
يبدو كثيرًا، ولكن إذا بدأت في
الاستقراء والتقدم سريعًا إلى
أبعد من ذلك في المستقبل، فإن القلق هو
أن هذه الأرقام ستستمر في
الارتفاع، ولكن مرة أخرى، هذا هو الحال في
المقام الأول  النساء لذلك لم يكن لدى الرجال
نفس الزيادة ولم ترى
نفس الزيادة في الأشخاص الذين تزيد أعمارهم عن
50 عامًا أيضًا، لذا أيها الجندي
السؤال الواضح هنا هو لماذا نعرف ما الذي
يمثل الزيادة
لسنا متأكدين وهذا هو  هذا
موضوع نقاش كبير الآن
داخل مجتمع الأورام الذي يحاول
فك رموز هذه الأرقام أولاً وقبل كل شيء، نحن
نعرف ما هي أنواع السرطانات التي
نتسبب فيها نوعًا ما في زيادة
سرطان الثدي على سبيل المثال سرطان الغدة الدرقية
وسرطان القولون  هؤلاء هم
الثلاثة الذين كانوا يقودون الأمر نوعًا ما، وكان هناك
البعض الآخر في القائمة أيضًا، ولكن
هؤلاء هم الثلاثة الأساسيون الذين تعلمون أنه
يمكن أن يكون مزيجًا من
شيئين حقًا، أحدهما هو أننا أفضل
في فحص هذه السرطانات منا
كان الأمر كذلك قبل 10 أو 20 عامًا، لذلك ربما
نكتشف ببساطة المزيد من أنواع السرطان التي يمكن أن
تكون جزءًا منها، لكن التحدث إلى أطباء الأورام
لا يعتقدون أن هذا يفسر
كل شيء، والشيء الآخر هو
أنه ربما في العصر الذي
يعيش فيه الناس الآن  في الثلاثينيات من القرن الماضي، كانت هناك
نسبة أعلى بكثير من
الأشخاص الذين يعانون من السمنة المفرطة مما كانت
تعرفه منذ 20 30 40 عامًا مضت، نعلم عندما
يتناول الأشخاص الكثير من الجلوكوز
ويطورون الكثير من الأنسولين نتيجة لذلك،
بالإضافة إلى تكوين الدهون في
الجسم والتي يمكن أيضًا أن تكون  السرطانات الوقودية بحيث
يمكن أن يكون ذلك أيضًا جزءًا منه فقط
العام المتعلق بالصحة ولكن هذه هي
نوع من النوع العلوي من
الفكرتين مرة أخرى، إنه موضوع
للنقاش حيث يريد الكثير من الناس
اكتشافه بشكل واضح لمحاولة جلبه  هذه
الأرقام أدناه
كيف يمكننا أن نمنعها من أن تصبح
مشكلة أكبر يا سانجاي،
حسنًا، أنت تعلم أعتقد أن أحد الأشياء
هو أننا ما زلنا نعرف أن هناك فائدة
في اختبارات الفحص، كما تعلم، لقد
فعلنا ذلك منذ شهر تقريبًا
تقرير يتحدث عن ارتفاع معدلات سرطان القولون
بين الشباب على وجه التحديد
أه الفحوصات يمكن أن تساعد بشكل واضح على عدم
التحدث عن الأشخاص في الثلاثينيات من العمر ولكن
بمجرد وصولك إلى الأربعينيات من العمر، تعرف إذا
كنت تتحدث عن التصوير الشعاعي للثدي
أو فحص سرطان القولون هناك
محدد  التوصيات هناك فيما يتعلق
بموعد إجراء فحوصات التصوير
الشعاعي للثدي بدءًا من سن 45 عامًا
ما لم يكن لديك تاريخ عائلي
ثم الحصول عليها بعد 55 عامًا سنويًا أو كل
عامين وبالنسبة لفحوصات سرطان القولون أه،
تبدأ هذه الفحوصات
مرة أخرى في سن 45 عامًا أيضًا على ما
أعتقد  أن المشكلة الأكبر هنا
مرة أخرى هي النظر إلى
الصحة العامة إذا كان هذا صحيحًا
ويبدو أن نفس الأشياء التي
تسبب السمنة يمكن أن تؤدي أيضًا إلى زيادة
معدلات السرطان التي
تغذي الجسم بهذه السرطانات في نفس الوقت الذي يتعين
علينا فيه  أشير إلى أن هناك
نسبة مئوية أعلى من الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
السمنة الآن مما كانت عليه عندما
كنت في ذلك العمر، عمري أكثر من 50 عامًا الآن
وأنت تعلم أنني لا أعتقد أنكم كذلك
ولكن تعلمون أننا نجد  أن الأشخاص الذين تزيد
أعمارهم عن 50 عامًا ظلت معدلات الإصابة بالسرطان
ثابتة نسبيًا، لذا قد تكون هناك
بعض المعلومات هناك بالإضافة إلى
ما يجب فعله في المستقبل